hello yes this is Valentin Maria Enders
personal assistant that's you're gonna
be all over her you realize that right
I'm on a developing you had an interview
with an Italian magazine targeting
active women's session after 40 no
little the cover Oh Klaus nice to see
you he's a great director just hear him
out I played Secret in my Lotus night
when I was 18 for me it was more than
wrong because you were secret only you
can be hiding alone the play tells a
simple story
an older woman falls in love with a
scheming girl that has a wrapped around
her little finger so who's gonna play
cigarette to women others she's 19 I
will play the one who drives her to
suicide don't think she's probably my
favorite actress you mean more than me
it's incredibly brave of you to take on
the role of Helena it's a way of dealing
with time I don't think it's company
figures that are keeping you up at night
it's keeping me up in desire for me I
think
can you leave without looking at me as
if I didn't exist
so-so
I don't know why I have to inflict this
on myself to sign a contract polygala
cost
figure something out
you make the play and you hate her you
don't have to take it out on me I'm he's
getting nasty [ __ ] written about me I
could honestly care less
times combines you can accept it
me neither I guess
you